alors c'était une télévision locale
non parce que là je veux dire comme ça
commence qu'après c'est une télévision
locale jeudi qui est à sauver la série
tout ça me tue dix tours il est installé
la côte et c'est comme ça que je les ai
connus
et puis que j'allais souvent les oies
pas tous les jours mais presque peuvent
l'être et non c'est pas tous les jours
mais pas tous les jours mais souvent
aussi et puis c'est comme monter leur
fils
[Musique]
à temps
ouais
oui
oui mais non
je sais pas
monsieur
regardez le reportage de la télévision
si vous vivez actuellement
alors on les applaudit bien fort après
cette victoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
bon pour la famille
[Applaudissements]
pour sa première émission il y avait
déjà tous les gars qui friment les
filles qui évite la caméra
la caméra indiscrète
[Musique]
les papilles intrigué et les fanfarons
[Applaudissements]
je
c'était effectivement les premières
images de télé sauget la télé broue les
acteurs de cette aventure se sont réunis
il n'y a pas très longtemps comme des
anciens combattants pour échanger leurs
souvenirs
certains ne s'étaient pas revus depuis
quelques années on a commencé par donc
se satisfaire de le cinéma il espère
qu'on allait vous voulez faire donc du
ciné-club dans les communes du soja
donc on avait parties sur la base donc
de louer des films trappe et de la faune
et donc on a on a commencé à faire ce cd
s'il se représentation de file et puis
pour attirer les gens donc à la séance
de films dominicaine l'idée qu'on fasse
l'après midi avant un film de trois
reportages vidéo dans le village où on
était et puis ça pas mal marché ça 78 à
la fin des années soixante dix le monde
rural se réveillaient et avait envie
d'animation la régionalisation de la
france se mettait en route et surtout la
vidéo dit les airs apparaissait c'est
ainsi que par hasard dans le haut doubs
est née une des premières télévisions
locales
mais personne ne savait encore
dans cette rubrique nous vous
présenterons les diverses activités
sportives et culturelles du canton
aujourd'hui un flash sur le ski dans les
secteurs de juillet et de montbenoit en
1976 à des maïs une secte de montbenoit
eu une équipe de jeunes révolue de
décider de vouloir développer le ski sur
les plateaux supérieur de les communes
de ville du pont d'autres la france et
des alliés alors cette association au
départ une réunion cavité peut lancer
frappé jeantet au niveau des jeunes et
une cinquantaine de jeunes qui disait on
il manque de chaussures sauget qu'il
faudrait faire du thé a des manques du
ski a que le foot à l'époque créé tout
est basé sur le foot 1 les clubs se
lancent à l'époque de foot
tout partait là dessus et dans cette
réunion paroissiale d'autres proposent
de faire un ciné club un jour ça tape
dans le cadeau c'est du culturel on a
les télévisions on va pouvoir déjà plus
que des tas de gens de chez nous enfin
jean d'extérieur donc il faut voir ce
qu'ils valent
on va laisser faire puis on les a laissé
monter ce qu'on appelait tel est son
objet on se disait où là il ya toujours
un danger
on en a un peu peur c'est vrai qu'on
leur connaît le recul on la connaît
alors qu'on aurait dû mieux exploiter ce
qui arrivait mais on va voir
[Musique]
à l'époque des majorettes l'état
giscardien distribuer des subsides aux
provinces
[Musique]
la technique n'est pas mis en danger
elle avait longuement animée grapo voilà
comment ça s'est passé de supers
rappelant lundi 4 70 80 l'état a mis un
paquet sur la franche comté à tous les
niveaux dont il ya eu des associations
qui ont été créés et qui devait servir
de moteur à nous ça et on avait un stock
de matériel un parc de matériels pour
les expositions pour le théâtre et
surtout comment gt2 nombre de permanents
étaient déçus bien ça va d'origine donc
on a monté les choses on a évidemment
pensé en vie en termes de l'audiovisuel
[Applaudissements]
agriculteurs dans le haut doubs entre
surprend là en plein mois d'hiver
différents bruits qui courent il paraît
que les paysans du haut doubs de forêt
en hiver ces sujets c'est ça s'appelle
vont 7 pompeusement une télévision quand
même c'est surtout de la vidéo
au départ il ya quatre ans
il a voulu créer un ciné-club de ont eu
de la chance un mauvais moi qui vais le
crtc qui étaient implantés là et il va
super parc matériel quoi il faut le dire
il dormait mr même type e
on a exploité à fond de matériel vidéo
qui étaient là mon premier réflexe vidéo
galles télé donc on a 10 ans ont fêté
les télés sont j'ai une expérience
sympathique qui à l'ère de la
communication pourrait bien s'étendre à
d'autres régions et pour terminer cette
image cette image qui pourrait être
prise comme un symbole par les
professionnels de la télévision ou pour
un simple incident de parcours
seul l'avenir nous le dira
on faisait ça tout simplement pour
animer la république du saugeais et même
le canton sans se rendre compte à
l'époque qu'on faisait certainement
partie d'un mouvement beaucoup plus
large
il y a à la libération un relatif
consensus assez large sur l'idée que la
télévision est organisé sous forme d'un
monopole est un service public qui est
encastré dans le monopole mais le
problème va se poser parce que ce
monopole va être confisqué par les
partis au pouvoir surtout à partir du
moment où la télévision devient
importante en france c'est à dire à peu
près à l'arrivée général de gaulle or 58
59 60
et il ya un contrôle politique d'abord
par de gaulle ensuite par giscard
pompidou ensuite par giscard d'estaing
et donc à une contestation qui va monter
contre cette télévision descendante
donc il ya des réactions contre cette
absence de pluralisme et c'est ainsi que
apparaissent des mouvements de
contestation à l'égard de cette
télévision mais déjà il y avait eu au
québec
et puis aussi dans d'autres pays plus
tard en italie des mouvements de
télévision associative qui contestaient
donc ce poids du monopole vers la fin
des années 70 il y avait précisément un
bouillonnement considérable qui touchait
à cette question des médias puisqu'on
était juste avant la libéralisation de
la loi sur l'audiovisuel
donc en fait à cette époque qu'il y
avait des expériences pirates de
télévision beaucoup de radios et c'était
précisément à ce moment là que sont nés
aussi ses vidéos de pays c'est
d'acquérir la fois ce bouillonnement
cette envie de parler de prendre en mai
la représentation d'un territoire et
c'est aussi ça s'est accompagnée d'une
de ce nouveau matériel qui arrive et ça
c'est très important parce que jusqu'à
maintenant la télévision était fait avec
des gens des gros équipe lourde et
télévision avec des caméras dans le
maniement était difficile et l' arrivée
la vidéo c'était beaucoup plus léger qui
avait pas de développeurs ont trouvé
avec à deux personnes un cadreur en
prenant de son on pouvait arriver à peu
près à faire quelque chose il y avait
des bancs de montage qui ce qui était
encore cher mais avait des centres de
ressources souvent pouvez utiliser ces
bancs de montage pour monter donc ça
devenait possible avec ce matériel de
faire de la télévision dans les
conditions techniques correct voilà
c'est vraiment une initiative de gens
qui disent on est sur un territoire on
vit on est bien sur ce territoire ont
fait beaucoup de choses et l'image qu'on
est du pays dans lequel on vit est
inverse de ce que l'on ressent de ce que
l'on croît de ce que l'on fait tous les
jours on va on va prendre une caméra
pour pour renverser ce regard cette
image et pour montrer justement que
c'est pas le cas
[Musique]
decroix teyssot gay
on y voit marie-chantal contre le
docteur k il s'agit d'une aventure
policière d'espionnage agréable et
amusant
réalisé par claude chabrol 04 l'a jamais
ça c'est pas appelé c'est des sujets de
tuchan non maintenant c'est un cinéma
itinérant du comité du canton veut nous
a traités de déménager quand même
l'écran l'écran se lever un peu il
fallait quand même costume
le projet l'unef il avait deux vitesses
le magnétoscope ayant du temps et des
pastels gros magnétoscope ou matic 34
ans brennan trois gammes premier rang
des grands espaces de banque qui
rappelle celle occasionnée
on a toujours de faire un cinéma
itinérant s'est arrêtée parce quand on a
eu du mal à trouver à trouver des bons
films aguirre la colère de dieu ou la
coupe à 10 francs d'oublier ça ça a fait
fuir un petit peu les pour trouver des
films correctement parce qu'il fallait
qu'on passe en 35 mm et on n'a jamais
trouvé le fric nous racheter une fois
des deux objectifs
et maintenant place au cinéma
[Musique]
diffuser un coup un dimanche dimanche
après-midi tourner faute à personne est
un petit bijou qu'est venu et puis on a
programmé tous les regards des courriels
mobiles a également remporté une donc
tous les mois les soirées était composé
de deux parties la télé locale pour
attirer les spectateurs et le ciné club
pour l'heure montré de bons vieux films
sur un grand écran mais il préférait de
loin se voir en noir et blanc sur un
téléviseur présidente je suis heureuse
très heureuse de vous accueillir dans la
petite république et puis surtout à
monde moines
vous êtes déjà venu temps points et m
nous gardons un si bon souvenir et vous
cher présidente c'est pour moi très
émouvant d'être auprès de vous nous le
connaissons depuis longtemps
vous savez que j'appartenais déjà un peu
la république du saugeais du temps du
président ou votre cher époux et vous
avez repris le flambeau
grâce à vous cette république est
actuellement en pleine prospérité et les
cités dans le monde entier
l équilibre son budget et la bonnes
relations avec tous ses voisins et
importe partout le message de la paix je
suis heureux d'être citoyen ni changer
c'est n'ouvrait sogest général de bab al
jadid les ramones elle vendrait fashion
en amande qu'affronte cas suspect d'air
en fermant les chocs
eh bien voyez vous j'ai fait des voyages
ces temps ci j'étais dans des pays
variés à l'union soviétique
j'ai été en république de mongolie
extérieure un pays très pittoresque
était situé dans les montagnes un peu
comme ici pelure d'ailleurs tous les
gens vont te caches val toute la journée
et là partout me demander d'où j'étais
je tiens voilà je suis un peu d'ici un
peu de là mais mon coeur et dans une
petite république française il s'appelle
la république du saugeais et bien les
gens étaient heureux de cela quand même
été remise en marche et si on veut nous
prendre s
[Musique]
mexique le président en raison
d'incidents indépendant notre volonté
les images de ce reportage présente des
rayures désagréable vous voyez nous en
excuser on avait un matériel demi pouce
qui était pas très commode parce qu'avec
le froid la bande se coller enfin cetera
et cetera
toi tu étais enthousiasme moi j'étais
enthousiaste si on ne sera lancée on a
passé beaucoup beaucoup de temps et
beaucoup de plaisir à rencontrer des
gens les gens de là où était simple pas
plus que sympa ils étaient vraiment
intéressés par la vie de leur canton
c'était d'autant plus agréable que même
si tu étais en noir et blanc même si
c'était pas très bon les gens se
déplaçaient pour
pour venir voir sur un écran télévision
un grand écran de télévision comme ça là
et ils se mettaient tous dans une salle
datant de regarder ça les intéressait il
s'est déplacé pour ça il sortait il y
affronter le il affrontait la neige y
affronter tout pour venir se regardent
et se parler boire un coup il avait fait
monter un théâtre tous les agriculteurs
et montrent un théâtre c'était un
théâtre rude rude enfin je veux dire le
curé en prenait plein plein plein plein
de lise enfin c'était vraiment assez
assez assez cru et quand on a monté on a
été convoqué chez l'abbé jean tu es là
qui était le doyen presque enfin le jeu
presque le chanoine du coin et qui nous
avait dit mais comment c'est pas
possible pas faire sa diva d'écouter ses
chats vous voyez ça avec votre hôte avec
votre confrère parce que nous on y court
juste filmé la scène le théâtre qu'ils
ont fait c'est s était simple c'était
super
gray valoir tf1
des techniciens du son grain l'ofppt et
l élisant dirait sur les trois gènes
nations non étrangère puisque nous
sommes deux projets la séance devait
voir c'est ainsi qu'est née télécharger
un enfant de la vidéo qui pourrait bien
faire beaucoup de descendants sont
concernés 16 communes du canton de
montbenoît 16 villages qui servent de
décor à la réalisation des reportages 16
villages qui servent de lieux de
projection à ses reportages
l'équipe de télé sauget 4 ou 5 personnes
selon les jours tout bénévole toutes
amoureuses de la vidéo et de leur canton
enfin telesso j'essaie plus de 4000
habitants
autant d'acteurs que de spectateurs
quels sont les sujets de reportage au
début on veut dire qu'on crée
l'événement ont filmé ce qui se passait
alors fait devant nous est de
l'événement five à une terme s a commise
on est aussi on allait aussi faire
défaire des portraits de deux personnes
quoi faire a porta sur deux deux petits
vieux la ville du pont les frères martin
et or fait et ce qui pour nous comme il
est dans le temps c'était ses pertes à
recycler le boulot qui remet pour faire
une paire de lentilles pasteurienne
decker voyez ça va envoyer pour débuter
pour faire une paire de skis faut des
gens du bois au moins trois ans
et puis après bolt éviter tout on
ébauche comme ça pour qu'ils se
retournent pas d'après bain ou le tamani
il faut du beau bien ses carreaux et
dubois clp autres mauriciens et fennec
est découpé en cinq ans il vomit il
fallait didier gentil c'est toujours
sans des coupes hesbollah la saint
martin sont pas protégés par du bois 3
ans l'évier gens disent toujours le
freine les vieux jamais il disait
toujours le beau le vrai il ses chansons
qui m'aide pas en serre dit tout de
mesures y est joint dans ce qui suit ce
fonds en provenance d'un grain de riz
fabriquées en 8es jeux des derniers vont
en fait c'est un modèle suisse ces
modèles on étudiera les suisses ils
n'ont pas plus beaux modèles côté
west bay a plus guère connu c'était
simplement jouer mais à l'ancien plan
alors que bien qu'elle ne rassure mais
je suis pas où elle en est
j'en avais marre et porter une planche
cookies les jets 10 ans et enfin comme
un espèce de trentenaires noël emporté
nombreux bleus on avait pris une de ses
gardes il ya été signé oui ou non loin
de janvry
mais quand vous étiez 10 12 mai où
disait il souvent la mapi qu'angoua
aujourd'hui ce qui m'intéressait c'est
justement ça ne ressemblait pas à ce que
faisait à l'époque fr3 c'est à dire que
le journal de fr3 c'est un journal qui
était calibré rubriques comme les grands
journaux télévisions ce qu'il faisait le
c'était autre chose qui prenait le temps
de laisser se passer des choses
moi même bien longtemps après j'ai
encore des souvenirs de documentaires
j'ai vu enfin de ce qu'elle ait tourné
de nogaret je trouve très intéressant
qu'on pouvait pas voir à france 3 par
exemple une vente aux enchères qui se
déroulait après la liquidation de d'une
exploitation agricole
le vieux bûcheron nous a quittés avec
l'été le 18 octobre
ces biens ont été vendus aux enchères la
présence de nombreux étrangers aux
songes et ont fait flamber les prix
et ces outils ont été éparpillés dans
toute la franche comté on ne peut
s'empêcher de regretter qu'en cette
année de patrimoine c'était moi de la
vie rurale n'est pas été conservé pour
la constitution d'un musée les
traditions du haut doubs 805 4 1 850
fois
[Musique]
essayons avec dès septembre mais qu'il
achète ça je n'ai pas de courant chez
eux la mettra comme cela mantas et grédy
des cercles sommes toujours ya preneur à
combien de celle ci nous apprend ça vaut
mieux que ça assaf le seyon s'avère une
fois
on
[Musique]
m
au bout d'un an ou deux d'expérience
toujours un noir et blanc
les animateurs bénévoles étaient de plus
en plus à l'aise avec l'outil vidéo et
jouer avec plaisir le rôle de reporter
jiwa
marie-claude c'est sainte catherine ce
soir oui vous êtes catherine les haies
les gens qui s'en lasser des copains
c'est quoi c'est des copains et copines
les campagnes travail des combats 12
comme chaque fois devant callà tour en
retard et c'est pas connu ça va
alors madame mais combien salé le
10/10/10 bête oui c'est à dire qu'elles
sont pas toutes arrivées encore un il à
quelle heure en ce moment 10 heures je
reconnais parfaitement que c'est les
difficultés mais je dis que c'est
intolérable et une situation comme ça le
paysan ça c'est une chose qui me déplaît
c'est tout ce que j'ai à dire
pour nous c'est tolérable m'ont donné
les ratios des prix et la compression
des prix agricoles
messieurs vous êtes confrontés dans un
marché et que nous récupérer puis on est
refusé par l'administration entière
messieurs au quotidien il admis je vous
alors moi je suis à l'art est la seule
possibilité de de tenir un peu mieux je
respecte tout le monde je vous montrerai
mon dossier de taxe professionnelle qui
augmente et je crois de 165% mais
l'administration je suis comme vous j'ai
écrit au préfet je vais et tout mais
personne ne fait rien pour moi allez bon
courage
oui le point de vue d'une vache pour
produire mon premier litre de lait une
me faut un hectare de terrain d'une
valeur locative de 600 lits pour
entretenir le terrain mon propriétaire
achètera du matériel agricole et de
l'engrais l'hiver il me faudra à
logements elle son assurance de la
farine et un docteur pour la grippe à la
fin de l'année je reproduis 3500 livres
de l'est disons à 1 franc le litre
mais les frais de mon propriétaire
seront de 3000 francs il ne lui reste
plus grand chose
heureusement au printemps c'est lui
donnerait un veau de six enfants
[Musique]
communiqué j'ai une mauvaise nouvelle à
vous annoncer
c'était la dernière émission de télé
sauget adieu adieu télé où j'ai un noir
et blanc
car dès le mois prochain vous verrez
tomber la neige en couleur sur tous les
sujets et maintenant tomber la neige qui
ne viendra pas ce soir
monde
métaux
valet
ma
[Musique]